there's three ways you can get leads
right one is you can manually assemble
the leads list the second way is that
you can buy leads from Brokers the third
way is that you can scrape leads using
software for me I usually will start
with
[Music]
Zev what's up man how's it going good I
have two questions
um sort of both different topics but the
first one is more lead related
struggling to figure out which method is
the best method to focus on so I don't
feel like I'm wasting my time you know
doing something to try to get leads who
are you going after the three main
avatars would be like Tech startups B2B
b2c SAS and then really any company that
has like a custom software so there's
three ways you can get leads right one
is you can manually assemble the leads
lists the second ways that you can buy
leads from Brokers and the third way is
that you can scrape leads using software
I usually will start with uh scraping if
I can because it tends to be the
cheapest and so I'll use like if you
just Google tool for whatever like what
you're referring to yeah yeah and then
I'll take the top four or five of them
and I'll run my search for avatars into
each of them and then I'll take a sample
of like let's say 100 or 500 leads of
each work all of them see which ones I
get the highest response rate and then
I'll double down to whatever platform
got me the highest throughput you're
saying which platform gets you the
highest response rate that we're
referring to which lead Source yeah I
mean in terms of reaching out to the
actual leads itself I reach out on
everything that sort of ties into the
next thing so one thing I've been
thinking about is you know how you talk
about to lead with sort of with value
offer something essentially for free so
that's like a big thing where I'm just
like not really sure how to even figure
out what we could offer being that like
am I like stepping is this like stuff no
you're good this is like I go through
this literal step-by-step process in the
book of everything that you're saying so
it's like how to figure out what you're
going to give the person for free how to
structure it how to make like here's the
script to get replies all that stuff
um so the good news is the book will
solve your problem but the best
framework that I can use for coming up
with things that people will reply to is
give them Something Free that they would
normally pay for so rather than be like
I made this amazing thing but if it's
the same free valuable thing that
everyone else gives then how you know
how good is it you have to compete being
significantly better but if you just do
something that normally other people
charge for even on a micro level and
they can ascribe real value to that
people will respond to you and then then
you're operating on a you're in a way
better frame and then you can have a
much better conversation the other thing
was more like on a personal side so if
we could just sort of step back when you
were sort of going through that you know
volatility of you had like success then
big failures and come back up in terms
of how you like structured your life if
you did it all so that you push put
yourself in the best position to where
like you're cutting certain people out
maybe you're bringing certain people or
that might be even resources for skill
development or whatever in how do you go
about doing that so that you're not
um doing things that don't really help
you move forward and grow uh long-term
big picture yeah so it's it's a really
good question because the number one way
to change your behavior is to change
your environment so if you change the
conditions you'll behave differently
right like if you're there's a red light
you act differently than a green light
and so that's a micro example of how we
act like in Baltimore when I live there
I act differently than when I moved
because I had I've had a clean slate
like I didn't have to talk to old
friends that would treat me a certain
way that then I would respond to in the
way that I didn't want to right and so
first thing from a people perspective
like I think a lot can be gained from
literally just moving 30 minutes away
like even if you like I can't move out
of you know I'm not going to move from
Baltimore to California okay that's fine
just move to the other side of town just
get just get out of the micro
environment the second thing that'll
then lead to is the people that you will
frequent will change right and I think
that you'll have to get accustomed or be
okay with the fact that you will lose a
lot of friends
and that's not a bad thing because the
thing is is like if if all you have in
common continues to shrink and shrink
and shrink and the only thing you have
left to talk about is the past remember
the good old times remember that time we
got so drunk at rippies you know I mean
like whatever then like they're not
trying to help you create the future
that you are ultimately looking for and
it just like I will say that as I've
gotten you know
further along in that path my time to
cutting people has just shrank because
if I figure if I'm going to cut this
person eventually I might as well cut
them now and start enjoying the benefits
of of not having them in my life and
having all this back and it's like all
those time if I have somebody just keeps
inviting me to and then making me
feel guilty or if I go out and they're
like why aren't you drinking or like why
aren't you like oh he's on another diet
you know whatever it's just like you're
not help like just asking the question
like how do you think what you're saying
is going to help me
and if there's like well I'm just giving
you a hard time it's like yep understood
how is that going to help me it's not
okay so like either change your behavior
or I will change it for you meaning I
will just not have you in my life the
third piece is that I remember there's
this video I had just uh opened my sixth
location and I was looking to open seven
through ten and I had already mapped out
where I was going to be opening them for
my for my gems
and I remember I did this Facebook live
and I was like beat up you know I mean
like I was tired I was taking I was
doing 12 hours of days of sale so I was
taking sales sales from eight to eight
every day and then I would still do the
rest of my work before and after that
and somehow trying to work out during
that period I remember saying what are
you willing to give up so I made this
live it was like these are all the
things I'm giving up now so like these
are things that I used to do that I'm
not going to be doing anymore so I was
like I'm not following the Ravens
anymore so I was a Baltimore Ravens I
was like I'm not I'm not watching
football I'm not looking at Fantasy I'm
not going to build a team I'm just on
Sundays I need to work like I can't give
the three hour I can't do it so I gave
up football I gave up Netflix I was like
that night time where like normally I
like d you know decompress I was like I
don't have time for that right now like
I got to process payments I gotta
process contracts I got filed with leads
and do reminders for the next day and so
it was changing where I was places wise
being okay with the fact that I was
going to have a period of a little bit
more Solitude because as soon as you cut
things you create room you create a
vacuum but new people will come in who
are like in this world and I would
recommend just connecting with people
online because there's so many there's
such bigger communities of people who
are trying to do the same thing online
versus wherever you're at locally right
and then the third is it's just like
what are my behaviors what are the
things I'm going to give up
in order like because you got to make
room like you only have 24 hours right
so it's like what are the things that
aren't getting me where I want to go and
the thing is if you just say I'm not
going to do those positive behaviors
will fill the Gap I think for me it
comes to more maybe a family side of
things or like those people I have a
different way of dealing with them their
family but like I don't know how to
necessarily navigate that so two things
first off I have very extreme views on
this so like just take that with a grain
of salt that you will right if we Zoom
all the way out like I didn't choose to
be born that was forced on me and so
like I don't feel like I owe anyone for
that right now that being said I believe
in Fair exchange or abundant exchange
meaning like I'm gonna make everybody in
my life's life better for being there
but I want them to also make my life
better right and so I think the first
layer of this is approaching it with
absolute Candor which is like what you
would tell me being like man my dad you
know he just treats me like I'm a kid he
always brings up these things like when
I was 14 years old and he keeps saying
up you know zeb's got a short temper you
know like my dad says that he's like
you're such a short temper right you
just always tell me that and so you have
to reset like you have to reset like
these are the rules of engagement like
if you want me in your life this is what
is required for me which is like you
cannot speak to me this way like if you
know your your big Uncle grabs you by
the neck and he's like I look a little
nugget you know whatever something like
I'm not saying he's doing that but I'm
saying it as an extreme example like
what would you do there you you're like
No And it creates like it creates a
moment where they're like oh now they'll
then probably try and shake it I'd be
like dude I was just kidding it's like
it wasn't funny I'd be like it's just
you and me and I'm not laughing
and then it's like whoa that's a new
tone right and so like you have to reset
boundaries have to reset the Rules of
Engagement and then the thing is is that
you have to enforce those which means
that at a certain point you have to
decide that I'm going to decrease my
communication Cadence I'm going to
decrease my proximity to you I'm not
going to be I'm not going to be as
accessible when you text me it might
take me a couple days to respond right
when you say Hey you gotta admit I might
not have a minute right like you have to
earn that
and like the fact that you are family
gives you more leeway
but not infinite and so one of the
unfortunate things about family is that
we treat family worse than anyone else
because we think that we can't lose them
and so I reject that notion entirely I
just I just don't I I believe in
treating everyone the same family and
stranger
and then if I can benefit them awesome
and if they can benefit me awesome and
then we both keep Like Loving our
relationship because we don't feel like
we're owed anything and so that's that's
bi-directional though because that's the
thing is if you're gonna play this game
in my opinion this is the way I play it
which is that you're like listen
I don't owe you stuff but it means I'm
also not going to say you owe me
anything and like we're starting there
that's how I approach those things
thanks for taking my questions
appreciate itself appreciate you good
luck man
hey Alex how is it going Selena what's
going on how do you strike the balance
between offering free value to pay
offers like when is the perfect time to
make that switch
so you give until they ask simple as
that you give and you keep giving and
you keep giving and you keep giving
until eventually people are like dude
what else do you have can I get this
from you like dude you've helped me so
much like could is there and what
happens is you'll start hearing what
different people want from you and then
you'll start noticing the common thread
and then you can ask permission from
your audience of the people that you are
providing this value to be like hey if I
did something like this would you guys
be interested and then take a take a
poll very easy right and if they say
lots of them say yes then it's like now
you have permission from the audience to
then say cool well I'm gonna go spend
three months building this for you and
I'm gonna give it to you guys just
because you give things away for free
does not mean that everything that you
do is free we give free stuff in order
to get more people interested and earn
more trust so that a longer time Rising
we can convert more people into
customers a purchase decision is a
prediction of future value right like
I'm gonna buy this thing because I
believe that after I buy it I'm going to
get in excess of whatever I paid for
right and the best way to increase some
increase someone's conviction that
they're going to get value from you in
the future is to provided value to them
in the present
and so that's the that's the whole game
and so I'll give you I'll give you a
different example so if I were to go up
to 100 people and say hey uh buy my
thing right I might get one person to
buy it because I might have caught them
on a good day and they're really
struggling whatever right
100 people and say hey can I solve one
of your problems for free
more than one person will say yes maybe
20 people will say yes and then from
those 20 people when you crush it for
them and then say hey by the way I
solved this first problem you now have
another problem that's a better problem
but it's still a problem and I can solve
that for you too in exchange for money
a way higher percentage of that 20 will
now take you up on the offer and then
you get half of those 20 to buy your
thing and you go from one sale talking
to 100 people to 10 sales so you can 10x
your conversion rate by just adding a
level of trust prior to the ask how do
you come up with idea and think about
okay
okay you have the idea honestly like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna dive a little a
level underneath is that you're not
accustomed to the level of work that's
required like real talk you're just not
used to it that's okay my level of
output and my understanding of how much
work capacity I have has continued to
increase over time I've put 200 hours
into the presentation that I'm going to
be giving on Saturday
most people don't put 200 hours into
their product
it's just it's just orders of magnitude
in terms of difference and so like if
people saw how much time I put into the
things they wouldn't be surprised by the
value
they'd be like well that makes sense you
spent 200 hours on actually I'm a little
embarrassed for the guy he spent he
spent basically five weeks of work hours
to make one you know 90 minute
presentation
and so I think that if you were to think
about like for you to actually spend
legitimately like working out or spend
200 hours on making something really
good
and that doesn't mean making it longer
it means making it better
and then give that away for free
and then what happens is if it really is
good
people will then share it with other
people and then you get double effect
you get more people to take you up on
the free offer and then their friends
send you other people
there's so much more work that goes into
it I spent six hours a day for two years
on this next book I work from six to
noon every day and then I take my
meetings I did that every day for two
years
and now I'm releasing the book right and
I feel very confident that it's a good
it's a very good product right and so
again I think my level of work in terms
of hours is probably greater than what
you're doing and I have a lot of stuff
going on right
but you just have to be able to block
the time and say the first four hours of
my day every day for this month are
making this thing and I'm going to make
you exceptional and the thing is
document you making it
show people how much work you're putting
into it and then when you do have it
they're like wow she really did this she
didn't just whip up a PDF that took her
a day I used to think that a day of like
all right this took me a whole day a
whole day in my mind was a long time and
the nice thing is that the the really
valuable fruit are right in front of
everyone it just has a very tall ladder
so you just have to climb a lot longer
than other people will to go pick the
fruit but it's right in front of you you
just have to spend way more time making
the thing exceptional which also means
that all the other distractions that
you're probably distracted on right now
are these little side projects this is
me just guessing right now right you
have to cut that because what you
realize is the amount of work that's
required to make something exceptional
precludes you from doing multiple things
like you can't do multiple things well
you can do one thing exceptionally well
and that means that you have to say no
to everything else yeah how do you find
that exceptional thing then it's not
that you find it you make it the more
you do the better you get and the more
you pull the thread on any of the things
that you're interested in the deeper
you'll go on it because you will get
better at it by very the very fact of
how much volume you're putting into it
so whatever it is that you help people
with
the one that makes you the most money
right now ignore everything else ignore
the other opportunities and say like how
do I how do I make this even easier like
think about the value equation how do I
make it faster for them how do I make it
less effort for them how do I increase
their perception of the likelihood that
they're going to succeed which means
that you know what I've been offering
one product but I really have three
avatars and so I need to just make this
tiny tweak here so that this person and
this person and this person will be
successful now if I was going to lean in
even more I would say just pick one of
the three and then exclude the other
ones just Master a puddle just be queen
of a puddle
and then you can be queen of a pond and
then queen of a lake and then queen of a
bay and the queen of an ocean right like
but you got to start with the puddle
because you're like half and half out
between different ones figuring out
what's my thing that I'm really really
good at and like spend a lot of time on
and perfecting that don't even think the
thing that you're really good at because
you might not be that good at anything
right now and I'm not saying that I'm
not that's not a wrap I'm just saying
like that's not a dig I'm saying
do the one that you forget about time
while you're doing it
and then you will become excellent
because you'll be able to actually keep
working like you have to solve for what
is the thing that I can work the most
like this amount of work is required to
get where you want to go right to be
exceptional and so then what you solve
for is how can I find something that I
don't mind doing this much work of but
this much work is required no matter
what
and if you do this much work whether
you're learning to be the best plumber
or the best architect or the best
whatever weight loss coach
that like if you can do that and forget
about time you'll win when I started on
YouTube I told the guy that was editing
my thing I said listen I'll do I'll do
three videos a week for 10 years I was
like and then if we'll measure whether
it worked or not
he's like I've literally never had
anyone say that so like what now it's
just like you have you need a
perspective shift thank you so much for
the opportunity and thank you so much
for the answer
Joe what's up man how are you doing Alex
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
awesome
um my name is Joe I'm in the gym space
I'm in the Britain Water Gym space the
space you move I know some stuff about
it I know some stuff about it and uh I'm
one of those guys who uh read Jim
launched a couple years too late I'm a
little older so I made all the same all
the mistakes he's talking uh talked
about when I felt like when I read the
book I felt like I was reading uh Deja
Vu I was like oh my God all these things
happen to me so my question to you is
um me and my business partner Dan are
launching a series of semi-private
personal training Studios we're still in
that space and we're launching one
shortly and so using the 100 million
dollar leads book that's coming out and
some of the stuff from gym launch and
100 million dollar offers what would you
do to launch a gym our plan every six
months for the next few years uh you
know until we get a number that we're
happy with and we keep moving forward my
my preference my preferred model is one
of two right now you're already doing
one of them so I won't even get into the
other one but I love the semi-private
model
um I love that like 300 400 a month
price point
um two to three times a week
um I like going after
avatars that have a little bit more
money specifically uh because for them
you know they're not gonna not pay
during the holidays you know I mean like
for them they're not going to be like
you know Breaking the Bank over 300
bucks
um and the nice thing and I think this
is this is I got this from Rick uh Rick
Mayo of alloy
um that model allows you to get to about
five six hundred thousand a year with
you know 1200 square feet 1400 square
feet like super small footprint
um and a single manager who's got maybe
10 20 profit share maybe like 40 50k
base and two helpers right so it's a
very simple lean model uh one on six one
on eight depending on how you want to do
it
um and you all you have to do is get to
120 ish at the location and it's usually
50 margin I mean I I have over time
simplified and simplified the model so
that there's just so little operational
complexity so that you can scale and
because if you're familiar with dunbar's
number yeah so the reason I like this
model is that like most micro gyms cap
at 120 to 150 and it's because the
systems required to purposely
manufacture human connection becomes
significantly more complex as you cross
that barrier right and so rather than
create this very very complex machine to
make it run at 600 you know service
based members I'd rather just have a
model that runs very profitably at 120
to 150 members and so
um lead gen perspective number one is
that I would do a three-month pre-launch
number two is that I would
disproportionately spend on the launch
so I would I would put like 30 grand
into the pre-sales and I would open at
full capacity the best gym franchises
know how to pre-sell so that they are in
the Black in the first month and like
every time I opened a new location like
is the first location was the one that I
didn't learn that I learned about the
lesson on my first one because I thought
I was trying to get it open as fast as
possible so I could make money but with
every everyone after that I tried to do
pre-sales as long as possible so I could
make all this money and not have to pay
any expenses and so that way you can
also Focus too because you can just sell
for three months do nothing but work
leads and and close contracts and then
after that you sh I'm sure you're what's
your turn right now for semis uh right
now only about five percent okay I mean
I I would shoot for three you know what
I mean but five's okay
um you know if you've got let's let's
just say five right and you got 120
members it's six members a month you got
to replace like it's just like it it's
so easy to replace that
um and just expect like if if you have
and what's your price point monthly
about 400 okay so 400 so that's an 8K
LTV right in terms of Revenue not profit
but like akl TV like you should be able
to spend 500 bucks to a Car customer and
not even sweat on it and so like if you
pay up to 100 bucks a lead local so that
you can close 20 of those into contracts
I'm not saying those are good numbers
I'm saying those are exaggeratedly bad
numbers
you'd still be fine
right because even if you had to close
Six customers the month it's three grand
a month in ads just to maintain it's
nothing now in general once you talk
about you know doing your six-week
transformation yeah do you still
recommend that as the primary giveaway
because that's all the rapper
can change you know what I mean like I
always call it's just wrapping paper on
the present but like we're still doing
nutrition we're still doing workouts so
like whether I do you know six weeks 42
days 21 days 28 days you know belly fat
blast metabolic reset like you know slim
by Halloween you know Lean by Halloween
you know that it's slim for Santa
you know big booty boot camp free
six-week challenge 42 day detox like a
done them all like at the end of
the day like all of those are rappers
that you rotate locally just so that
your ads don't fatigue but you want to
always push it into the same sales
process so that the Ops don't change so
it's like the adult change and then you
get on the phone you're like hey what
made you sign up for insert name or
promotion they're gonna be like well I'm
kind of overweight and you're like great
what have you done so far right you
start going through it so my second
question is you know with a business
partner who you know we have kind of
like uh different personalities would
work really great together 17 years of a
great partnership how do we how do you
manage or what would you recommend my my
preferred mode is take risk scale fast
like we have momentum we're maxed out in
both our other gyms we have a great
local reputation and recognition and I'm
like let's do you know let's do 10 of
these in the next like three years and
he's like lose his mind over it like
he's more of a prove it guy in your
experience you know
what's better you know speed yeah or or
or prove it you're both right a good
partnership has a yes man and a no man
right and so like in my Dynamic with
layla it's like I'm yes she's no right
and that's basically how everything gets
managed if you're up to me we joked like
we would have 100 businesses if we're up
to her we'd have none he says no because
he's knowing how much work it is right
like if you're the promoter and the you
know CEO whatever you want to call it
then there's usually more like strategic
works there's leadership stuff but in
terms of like day to day they usually
bear the brunt of the work and so it
costs more to them it's more painful and
so I'll I'll give you my advice from
what I would do having now worked with
an implementer for a long time is I say
what would you need to see for us to be
for you to feel comfortable with us
doing that and then she'll say here's
the checklist if you do these things and
you make sure these are the things that
are that are done we can do the next one
and then that way we have an agreement
and it's like and to be clear if we do
the same checklist at location three you
feel good again like yeah I'm good again
if we have these things
and so and then you're and then you're
aligned and then it's like cool let's
just keep the party going that's perfect
yeah that's great that's great advice
thank you so much I'm really excited and
grateful for everything you've given out
to the community of strength for sure
appreciate it man thanks y'all
Nicole what's up I don't know if you
remember me we met at Eric's yeah
Mastermind so
since then I started a podcast
um doing pretty well I made most of my
money as a Creator doing brand deals so
for example I was big in in the crypto
space the second I started my podcast I
had like a six figure deal which coming
to an end I don't think it's going to be
renewed everyone that everyone that I
talk to is like Nicole you've grown on
all these social Pages
um not just my personal but like you
know other brands that where I'm like
curating other people's content and
everyone's like it's a no brain
or do a newsletter
um I talk I talked to sahil bloom for
example you know who sells ads in his
and that's his his model
um but you know then I also heard you
say recently that like subscribers and
followers don't really mean anything
like they're a vanity metric and you're
like the game is now click retain reward
what exactly does that look like because
I like it's like currently I have
nothing to sell you up you're good
you're good so it's it's it's two
separate applications so from the growth
perspective like growing the audience
getting more people to see your stuff
like that in that world subscribers I
mean Tick Tock has changed the game in
terms of how all the algorithms work
right like right now if you have 10
million subscribers on YouTube if your
next video sucks it's not going to get
views period yeah it works same thing
with Instagram you see people with 10
million per you know 10 million accounts
make a post and it's got 300 likes on it
right
um it's because on the flip side though
it's good for new creators because you
can come on with zero followers make a
banging video and get 10 million views
right and I actually think it's a good
thing for everyone because it equalizes
the playing field it makes content King
like the quality of what you put out
which I'm always down to compete on that
and so
um so that's from the growth perspective
from uh building out a newsletter like
one is top of funnel the newsletter
subscribers I mean that like those are
customers you know what I mean and so
I I'm in no way against having you know
a new a newsletter of any sort that
provides value especially to a niche
audience because
um a buddy of mine um has a ton of data
on unsubscriber stuff and like the ones
that do the best in terms of LTV and
whatnot are typically uh hyper Niche and
high value so usually a little bit
higher price point
um but very specific to like the
because they are so Niche they can
provide an extent like a lot of value to
a person versus being like super wide
it's very hard to provide tremendous
value to everyone right it's kind of
like Elon musk's thing of like you can
either provide a little bit of value to
a lot of people or a lot of value to a
few people and so I think if you feel
like you're better at a specific Niche I
I think I think it makes sense for you
to go top of funnel is just get really
good at making content and then that
just converts into your subscriber
network uh so your newsletter and then
you sell ads to the newsletter if you
want to from an endorsement perspective
you can also have your own products if
you want to
um but you just become a media business
at that point which is fine I mean I'm a
big fan of media businesses okay that's
really helpful the other question that I
had your Dynamic is so different than
what we've we've seen in like
traditional relationships yet it still
works and you guys kill it so what
what's that Dynamic like and how is it
different and why do you feel like you
guys thrive
we set out to solve a different problem
with our relationship
and so I think that the premise that
most people come into the relationship
with is different than how Leila and I
approach the relationship and I think
that's where I think fundamentally like
you know like when you're solving a
business problem I'm sure you've
probably asked this it's like what
problem are we solving right it's like
the first question you're asked is like
what problem are we solving and so most
people don't even a ask that but B if
they do ask that
um they're usually trying to solve a
different thing they're like I want to
have lots of romance and this big
Hollywood love which from everything
that I know is something that is
short-lived and then disappears and then
you are left with someone that you're
looking at and you're like well
what do we have in common right and so
Leila and I had both rode that that
roller coaster multiple times before and
we're like and we both were at a point
where we're like you know what and mind
you I was very you know dejected at the
time when I met her I was like listen
I'm not trying to do anything I'm trying
to build this this is what I'm doing and
the first 30 dates we had were 30 days
in a row where after our first date
which we went to frozen yogurt the next
date was not a date I was like I'm gonna
be working from nine until I go to sleep
so if you want to work with me you can
and so that was what we did every single
day is that I was like I'm going to be
working if you've got work we can work
together and so it ended up just being
somebody that I enjoyed a lot spending a
lot of time with and the romance stuff
honestly I feel like didn't really like
kick in until like two and a half years
into our marriage and I think that our
relationship was based on that like
respect was first and then we learned
the love part it's very hard to learn
respect being hot or being physically
attracted to somebody I feel like is
that it's the ticket of Entry it's not
like I see a lot of successful guys go
find the the Instagram model I meet said
Instagram model and I'm like how do you
live like this like I would I would kill
myself if I had to talk to this person
every day right and they're like oh the
secret is I don't talk to him I'm like
that sounds horrible right and so again
it's like they were solving a different
problem and so for me my goal is always
has always been number one like where I
want to go right and having somebody who
wants to go that way with you because I
was engaged prior to Layla right
wonderful girl
um but we ultimately ended up deciding
to cut it off because we simply had
different goals for our lives she was
like I want to do this and I was like I
don't want to do that and it was like
what are you gonna do and we're like
maybe you're a great person and I'm a
great person we're just not necessarily
like meant to be and that's okay because
I think on some level like we say these
things like non-negotiables but then we
negotiate
and so it's like either it's a
non-negotiable or it is negotiable and
for me it's like where I want to go is
not negotiable so it's like I have these
goals which is where I want to go my
values which is how I want to get there
and then lifestyle which what are my
interests right and if I can find
somebody wants to go the same place the
same way and have and likes doing the
day-to-day the same way as me then I'm
good like the fact that Layla was into
fitness was like great I go to the gym
too you go to the gym like it's not
going to be weird you're not going to be
like oh I don't want to you know like
she's in the same mindset of that right
if I'm like hey I want to go invest in
this Workshop or something she's not
gonna be like I can't believe we're
spending ten thousand dollars on this
it's like
that that person who say that is not my
partner and I think um in terms of me
being the guy telling you what like the
number one thing that attracted me about
Layla was that Layla never tried to
change me
if you want to do big things then
whoever is going to come along with you
has to be equally big as a person
and I think a lot of people settle for a
45 000 employee
I mean and you can even if someone in
the reverse if I were you and someone's
like man I'm looking for a wife and I'd
be like what are you looking for out of
a wife like real talk like not
politically correct like what are you
actually looking for and so then if
they're like man I would love it someone
cooked and cleaned and fed me and and
washed my clothes and ironed and blah
blah blah you're like okay question if I
paid someone 45 000 a year to do that
professionally
then what would our relationship be
because that that's an expense you know
what I mean like we can just write the
check and like all those things are
solved so like now what
Andy what's up man what is up Mr Alex
hermosi okay so question I have for you
I've heard you talk a lot about
investing in the s p me instead of the s
p index like the me 500 right what would
you say with those skill Acquisitions
like which skills and in what order
would you suggest maybe a person to go
through because that kind of ties into
your skill stacking is there a
methodical way that you think yeah this
naturally ascends to the next one I
would think about it from the order of
how you would actually make money so
it's like well I have to have something
to sell right so you have to have some
sort of Base skill that you could sell
if you're going to get into services or
have some sort of Base product right
once you know how to do that so like if
you're getting an e-commerce you have to
build a store talk to manufacturers make
the thing that you're going to sell step
one on the services side it'd be like
what's the key skill that I'm going to
acquire to show people how to do it and
you can acquire that skill by like
working a job buying a certification
going through a course going to a
workshop like I learned I learned how to
run Facebook ads at a workshop you know
what I mean it cost me three grand at
the end of the workshop I knew how to
run Facebook ads and so and that three
thousand dollars has made me
many more than three thousand dollars
over the rest of my career so
point being first thing you start with
the thing right the second thing you do
is that you have to focus on promotion
so it's going to be advertising and if
you think about this is the order I did
the books right offers is what answers
the question what do I sell and leads
answers the question who do I sell it to
right so like once you have the thing
then you've got to go sell the thing and
let people know about it and you have to
advertise and so that is that is that
would be the second big skill stack the
third one would be conversion which is
like kind of persuasion so sales and
there's different ways you can do it so
like you could learn how to build you
know shopping pages and e-commerce that
convert you could take phone sales you
could learn how to to pitch and make
vsls all of those things and then
finally if you want to like learn the
next piece would be leadership and
operations because then you're gonna
have to hire people to help you out with
the the caliber people you work with and
the different levels that they're at has
there been anything that you would say
maybe is the common one or two missing
principles that most business owners are
not doing or if it's maybe questions
that they're not quite asking it you see
like sometimes if you only do like the
one or two things not that they're not
already what are they yeah so I just did
a tweet the other day but like the
difference between you know a thousand
and a million uh is skills right the
difference being a million and 100
million
is character
difference in 100 million in a billion
in my opinion we'll see if it works is
time and so once you have the base
skills then it's really becomes about
who the person is and so as you scale up
the speed of scaling often correlates
with the speed of talent recruitment
because if you are a shitty person or
shitty boss or a bad leader or can't
have cast a vision or can't explain why
this is going to benefit a lot of people
not just inside the business but also
outside the business then you're not
going to get the best people and if you
don't have the best people you have to
work overtime and then you never really
are able to pull yourself out of the
business and so you can measure the qual
you know the size and the scalability of
the company by the talent that they can
attract like there's a reason that
Google and meta and Goldman Sachs and
all of these ones pull from all the
Harvard you know all the Ivy League
schools and all that stuff and you know
we make fun of those people but they
also make all of the money and so it's
because they go they have a brand and
they have a huge pipeline of uh training
that they train people on and people
also know that when they go to that
brand Goldman Sachs McKinsey whatever
that they're going to be able to go and
do whatever they want afterwards and so
like what happens is you realize that
there's a two-sided funnel right so on
one side you have to learn how to
attract customers but on the other side
you have to learn how to attract talent
because if you just only know how to
track customers then everything always
breaks and you can never get over the
hump and you can never scale brilliant
brilliant great man well man thank you
for reaching back and helping all of us
go forward and taking the shortcut
uh how would you approach creating
strategies to generate leads and
cultivate enduring customer
relationships in this rapidly evolving
Enterprise B2B landscape right when I
say Enterprise let me clarify I'm
speaking to Fortune 500 uh Global 2000
type organizations I'll tell you two
very different things
um on one hand I've got a buddy who
sells only to Fortune 100.
um and he was telling me that one of
their most profitable strategies was
hiring people from The Fortune 100 in
the Departments that they're trying to
get on board
and then they hire them and they already
have all the sway all the influence all
the no all the know-how and then they
can bring that account with them and
then the majority of their revenue
actually just comes from cross-selling
all the different uh markets that those
people are in right so it's like okay I
had to start with you know Google
Southwest whatever right and then I then
I'm moving on to Google Mexico Google
Latin or whatever right
um and so those are the two biggest
areas of expansion from that perspective
in terms of the Legion like
I don't think the legion really changes
very much I think more or less it's just
how quickly can I involve as many
stakeholders as possible and make sure
that my pitch is oriented to them
looking good and them having no risk
in terms of their job it's like here's
my path to you getting promoted in a
raise and here's there's no downside
like it's all about them you know what I
mean but I think I think part of it is
like and I'm assuming you're a leader in
the company
um
I think a lot of it is really getting
the commission breath out of the sales
guys
um and oh this is like I'm getting the
tactics but
um is you know I love the term bam fam
right book a meeting from a meeting
which is that we never have anyone
falling through the cracks like we
always know what we're doing to move the
ball forward and I think some guys get
tired or they don't say lazy but like
they get tired and they're like yeah I'm
waiting for a response from that it's
like well when are when are you meeting
with them it's like well I'm waiting for
the response
it's like if you're not if you're not
able to push the ball forward from one
meeting to the next like that in my
opinion is a loss like that's a that's
like a missed sale even though maybe you
could save it but you can dramatically
decrease the pipeline because even
setting the frame with the Enterprise
sale of listen
normal Enterprise sales take 12 months
18 months six months depending on the
thing that you're selling if you explain
to the prospect you're like listen it
actually doesn't take 12 months it takes
48 hours
of work not time
so if we have 48 one-hour meetings to
get this done we can just take that and
we can stretch it over two years or we
can do it in three three months it's
really up to you and I think even just
setting that breaks a little bit of the
like this feels fast kind of language
that a lot of like more corporate people
will use and then making sure that the
bean counters who are approving budget
like hey I'm just been real
um yeah that that that their asses are
covered and that they can look good
yeah for sure no well it's all good
feedback my friends so uh just a quick
follow-up question then I'll let you go
uh regarding lead gen specific you know
the companies we can compete against
you're very familiar with McKinsey
Boston Accenture right uh seems like a
lot of little league gen is uh based on
content specifically gated content
um and you know part of your value
equation that I really like is you know
value on the front end which is kind of
difficult at the Enterprise level
um any thoughts there uh moving forward
is that do you see that you know kind of
staying the same maintaining that I
think that's 100 yeah I mean I think
it's the same reason McKinsey for
example puts out all those white papers
and Goldman Sachs put all their industry
analysis out right and you opt in you
get it and then they'll follow up with
you and I think I mean in my opinion
this may be an oversimplification but
I'm a simple guy like I'll I'll get the
name from anywhere in the org that that
downloads the thing that's valuable for
them and then that's where the scripting
comes in of the Judo of like hey you got
this thing what are you getting this
thing for well we're working on this
initiative whatever it's like well like
what's you know you get into it like you
get into sales like what's the objective
what are you guys trying to do cool well
who else is involved and then you start
and then you start moving your way
through the York so I want to pull the
thread from wherever I can
I'm sorry get the thread and then just
start pulling my way
no that's that's great stuff man I
really appreciate it uh looking forward
to the new release on Saturday man
thanks brother appreciate you Tom